the weapons that we use to fight fear
they're not brutality they are not wrath
they are not hate they are and will
always be loved
we're in the midst of an epidemic right
here along
[Music]
a lot of bad things in my life things I
now regret if you really want to leave
clay and your first step is admitting
what you do and he's little back to
where he belongs on these people are my
family
mm-hmm look we've got you
[Music]
can't get rid of a mystery replace it
with something Miller
[Music]
you got no food they living out of the
car am i understanding that you would
like a rule for that man you know who
that man is
I know of as a brother in Christ and her
so what you gonna do I'm praying for
some kind of sign it dis iniside then I
don't worry
[Music]
a man in his house you got an order
Klansmen I'd know Klansmen no more
[Music]
you don't lead a clan then he's in you
we ain't ever gonna stop
[Music]
they may set crosses burning in the
middle of the night
but we will fill the night with a
different kind of fire
but maybe one day y'all can forgive me
hope God can forgive me
you